did you two boys get to see you before
you stepped out tonight they did I got
yes Noah was so cute because he said
Mama and looked me up and then I was
like yo man
you gotta chill you got the swag doesn't
he he's so funny and Titan was like
Mommy you look really great I said Thank
you so yeah you wish you could bring him
to a night like this no because I
actually get a chance to be an adult I
will say your friends are here and it
feels like ladies night because it is
going to be ladies night I'm so excited
and so excited to see
um darling Kim be honored I feel like
she does so much beautiful work and
she's such a great human being I mean
the exterior is one thing of her being
this ooh Kim Kardashian but her heart is
a really great heart and like she works
behind the scenes like she does things
we don't even know that's public that's
but that's when you know somebody's like
really a good human like they they don't
care about the look you know of giving
like I've heard about different things
that she's done that people don't get to
see or hear about and that's the stuff
to me that counts the most so um it's
deserving for her to be honored tonight
so are y'all gonna cuff it up tonight
are you like Mom and moms are out and it
would be fun I mean get one get hold of
home what is it what is this
[Music]
have you done it yet you got to do it I
know I should do it with Titan right I
should do it myself for sure I could see
The Vibes Hey listen you got a lot going
on do you have pickled coming out on CBS
it's so fun are you into pickles can you
tell me how to pickleball I don't even
learn it so don't ask me don't ask me do
not ask me I have no idea I could see
The Jamie Foxx sells pickleball paddles
did you know that I heard about that
yeah I heard about it and then also
fantasy football with Marcy Martin no
I'm so excited we were putting that sag
card to work
I am very happy very grateful to God to
be so uh long into this industry and
still get the cause it could not be like
that you know so I'm just grateful for
every opportunity every call and figure
out the next step you know there's so
much to do I'm gonna say what is next oh
when you'd like to know I do can I tell
you I want to know Biden's plan to make
Commander our new national anthem oh
honey because that is my I'm ready to
battle after that let's listen to that
you know what I need to make about a lot
of that song we definitely to take us
into these next I need more of that
Kelly yes we we all need more of that
but thank you thing real quick uh we're
doing a special on Quincy Jones's 90th
birthday do you want I know do you want
to wish him a happy birthday or share an
antidote of like what he means to you
Quincy
some of my life's most pivotal moments
were either solved because of uh
a moment that you had in an instrument
that really ministered to me from
[Music]
and I can't help it if I mean I mean
it's just so many moments I mean he's
given us so much musical history and I'm
just so grateful to him grateful for his
musical genius this this that he is he's
just forever and Timeless and I'm just
grateful for his soul and his Spirit we
are grateful for him he is truly a icon
foreign